Sarah pressures on public services there are pressures on public services and immigration is one of the pressures on public services but the reason why our national health service is failing this is of David Cameron's government look we've seen five years of the NHS going backwards we've seen five years of a top-down reorganization that nobody wanted and nobody voted for and people's experience in A&E people's experience waiting longer for operations that can be turned round in a show up for finally that labor labor started that well I mean I already isn't mentally ladies and other ladies that I'm proud of our record on the NHS when we took over in 1997 be waiting 18 months waiting 18 months then it was 18 weeks and now we've seen the NHS going backwards and backwards on the David Cameron and I really fear for the future of the NHS with his extreme spending plans that's why we've got a plan to turn it round and